الى حاله اقتصاديه غذائيه غريبه ازمه
البصل الذي يدمي العيون ويشعل ازمه عابره
للحدود سبب هذه الازمه هو الارتفاع
الجنوني في اسعار البصل وتحولها من ازمه
تنتقل من بلد الى بلد في سوريا مثلا كشفت
ازمه البصل عن مشكله اساسيه في التقديرات
الحكوميه حيث تم تصدير جزء كبير من
المحصول لتبقى السوق المحليه بدون كميات
كافيه لبنان ثانيا الماذون اصلا في ارتفاع
الاسعار وانهيار القيمه السوقيه لليره
اللبنانيه يتفاجا اللبنانيون من سعر البصل
هناك ليبيا من جهه ارتفعت فيها اسعار
البصل بنسبه 300 فهل تتحمل العائلات
العربيه المزيد من الارتفاع الجنون
للاسعار في ظل الاعتماد الكبير عليه
الى لميس
ازمه البصل تشعل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
منذ اسابيع من عروس تحمل باقه من البصل
الى البصل يساوي دولار وغيرها في العديد
من الحالات التفاعل واذا عدنا الى اساس
المشكله فانخفاض انتاج البصل في ابرز
دولتين مصدرتين الهند باكستان بسبب سيول
وفيضانات الحقت اضرارا كبيره بمواسم البصر
اخذت معها ازمه البصل طابعا عالميا لاسيما
بعد ارتفاع سعره بشكل جنوني وشهد سعر كيلو
جرام الواحد من البصل ارتفاعا خلال الاشهر
الاخيره في الفلبين ليصل الى 800 بيسو اي
نحو 16 دولارا داخل متجر العاصمه مانيلا
وتخطى سعر البصل في الاسواق اسعار الدجاج
واللحوم في لبنان ضجه الوسائل الاعلاميه
بخبر ارتفاع سعر كيلو جرام البصل الى
70000 ليره وذلك بعد التدهور سعر صرف
الليره في السوق الموازيه حيث وصل الى نحو
70,000 ليره ايضا كما قفزت اسعار البصل في
ليبيا بنسبه 300 خلال الشهر الجاري
بالمقارنه مع اسعاره خلال شه رين يناير
[موسيقى]
على كل من بغداد تنظم الينا مراسله صباح
العربيه زينب المشاط وتحديدا من سوق
الخضار في طرابلس مراسله صباح العربيه
يسعد صباحكما رينا وزينب ابدا معك زينب من
بغداد ماذا عن ازمه البصل هناك حدثينا
اكثر عن الازمه بالتفصيل
صباح الخير طبعا احنا اليوم نتواجد في
يعني اكبر سوق للخضار في العراق اللي هو
يسمى بعلوه جميله هذه السوق هو الذي يعني
يورد لتجار الخضار يعني
الخضار هنا تحديدا يباع البصل بواحد دولار
امريكي يعني الكل واحد من البصل بسعر
الجمله وبعد واحد دولار امريكي فكيف تجار
الخضار يعني اصحاب محاليل البقاله يبيعوا
به تقريبا واحد ونصف دولار امريكي وهذا
السعر يعني يفوق القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين الطبقه المتوسطه او دون
المتوسطه خاصه وان البصل هو مكون رئيسي في
المطابخ العراقيه طبعا الازمه بدات
بالعراق مع اعلان الازمه بدات بالعراق مع
اعلان وزاره الزراعه في لبنان بايقاف
تصدير البصل الى العراق ايضا العراق معروف
بعد 2003 لانه هناك ضعف كبير المحاصيل
الزراعيه في العراق بعد 2003 خاصه البصل
ومحاصيل اخرى كثيره طبعا والعراق يعتمد في
يعني بالاستيراد المحاصيل هذه الزراعيه
وايضا ازمه ثانيه اللي هي تخلخل اسعار صرف
الدولار مع
استيراد هذه المنتوجات فهذا يسبب ازمه
كبيره يعني في السوق العراقيه
وزاره الزراعه قدمت حلول
احكيلنا على الحلول لوزاره الزراعه وزاره
الزراعه قدمت حلول يعني جزء
المواطن طريفه جدا اثارت سخريه الشارع
تقريبا بان وزير الزراعه اعلن عن
حاليا يعني البصل اليابس اسعاره مرتفعه
لان هناك تحول موسمي وانتقال موسمي فهذا
امر طبيعي جدا على المواطن ان يتكيف معه
ويعني يستبدل شراء البصل اليابس بالبصل
الاخضر الذي هو
من البصل اليابس ويعتمد على شراء البصل
الاخضر فقط في هذه المرحله لحين طبعا يعني
عبور الازمه المواطنين اليوم يعني
يتعاملون مع الموضوع على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
بسخريه يعمل المواطن كل يوم بعض المواطنين
طبعا يعملون جرد على اسعار المواد
المحاصيل الزراعيه يوميا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
اكيد سمعنا هيك مجمل كل اللي عم بيصير
وكمان الاصوات في لبنان تعالت اليوم هذه
الاصوات انه لبنان يصدر كثيرا من البصل
الى الدول العربيه ومن بينها العراق خلينا
نروح لرينا نفهم ازمه البصل في لبنان
ريناد لما انا اروح اشتري بصل بسوق خضره
ويقولوا لك انه كي للبصل ب 75 الف ليره
واذا حكينا عن ثلاثه اكياس مع بعض بيطلعوا
ثلاث ملايين ونصف شو يعني
يعني حتى بلبنان ما عاد فينا نقول كل بصل
ونصلي حصل يعني البصل هو سلعه استهلاكيه
شعبيه دايما كانت مرتبطه بالرخص يعني نحن
مرات بنقول بيع الدنيا بقشره بصله او صام
وفطر على بصله للدليل انه هذا شيء ما كان
يحسب له المواطن اللبناني حساب اليوم
البصل بيدخل بكل اكلاتنا حتى انا يعني كنت
عند الخضار قبل كم يوم ونحن ما بنشتري
البصل بالكيلو بلبنان يعني مقويه قلبي وعم
بشتري قال لي مدام يعني ما تتهوري بالمزح
لانه قال لي انه يوم في ناس ما قدرت حتى
تشتري بصل ويفضلها تشتري خبز في ناس
اشتريت بصله واحده هذا كله طبعا بفرجي عمق
الازمه بلبنان ولو هي عندها ابعاد عالميه
يعني نحن كما نعلم انه ارتفاع سعر البصل
مرتبط
بتراجع الانتاج باكثر دولتين مصدرتين
بالعالم اللي هم الهند وباكستان ولكن حتى
بلبنان كان عنا بعض الاضافات يعني المزارع
اللبناني زرع بصل اقل هذا السنه لانه كان
في كاسات بين الموسم السنه الماضي
وبالتالي لبنان اصلا يعني يستهلك تقريبا
ينتج تقريبا نصف حاجته من البصل وكذلك كان
في عامل رئيسي اخر هو اقدام احد التجار
على شراء كل الموجود من البصل بلبنان
وتصديره الى ليبيا هيدا خلى القفز
الجنونيه لا سعر البصل تتصدر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وتتصدر انشغالات
اللبنانيين رغم كل الازماتهم انا عجبوني
كل كمان الاقوال والامثال الشعبيه عن
البصه حابه اعرف اذا في بالعراق كمان هيك
اقوال شعبيه او
امثال مثلا على البصل شو زينب عندكم مثل
اللي سمعتنا اياهم رينا اربعه خمسه
عندي بعد يعني امثال شعبي يعني البصل احنا
احنا بس ناكله بالمطبخ هوايه يعني استخدم
البصل هوايه في الف صحه
مضبوط مثل كمان شكله عندرينا في كمان
اضافات خلينا تسمعنا رينا رينا
نادين نحن حتى البصل يعني يقال انه يلي
دخل بين البشر البصله وقشرتها او حتى مثل
البصله داخله بكل اكله هو يقالوا
للمتطفلين لانه البصل هو موجود بكل المطبخ
اللبناني وبالتالي نحن نعتمد عليه وما
بنعمل له حساب يعني بالايامات العاديه وان
شاء الله كمان
مزيد من الامثال عن البصل شكرا جزيلا لك
رينا دويه من طرابلس شكرا لزينب المشاط من
بغداد شكرا لكمما
خلينا نعطي المشاهدين معلومات عن اول ازمه
اقتصاديه في التاريخ او اول انهيار تاريخي
في الاسواق للمفارقه كانت هاي الازمه ازمه
وصل طبعا البصل الذي كان بطل الازمه
التاريخيه الاولى هو بصل ازهار التوليب
الذي وصل سعره في النصف الاول من القرن 17
ما يوازي 100,000 دولارات في ايامنا اليوم
على فكره كانت الاسعار تتضخم بشكل كبير
جدا وبدا الناس خصوصا في هولندا بالمضاربه
في البصل يعني حتى اصبح حاله جنون في كل
اوروبا البصله الواحده ينادين كانت تباع
خمس مرات دون ان تكون موجوده اصلا واو
مثلا اذا عدنا الى عام 1637 يعني هذا
قراناه في التاريخ
انفجرت فقاعه البصل وحصلت اول ازمه
اقتصاديه حاده في التاريخ فقاعه وصل
يعني مهم تاريخيا والمشكله كمان رمضان
كريم قريب كل طبخاتنا العربيه